well thank you for being here everyone
it was you say it's so gracious of me to
come out here thank you for the
invitation but it is also great to
escape Michigan winter for a few days so
I jumped at the opportunity to do that
um today I'm going to be presenting on
an intersectional approach to accessible
Computing and I'll I'll get into what
exactly that means but first I want to
lead with this premise right that human
computer interaction really aims to
Center humans in Computing Computing
related decisions and design
Etc
but this isn't always the case so then I
phrase this question of what happens
when we do not do this our intentions
are that we are doing doing so in ways
that are meaningful that supports
communities and helps communities Etc
but that is not always the case so I
want to just share a few examples
um that have popped up over the last I
don't know five or so years
um one is around so gender bias uh this
is a screenshot from an article on
Amazon where researchers reveal that
Amazon's hiring tool exhibited gender
bias where it was biased against resumes
and applications that contained the word
women's in any case whether it was a
particular Women's University or
organizations that someone was part of
it negatively ranked
um people with the word women's in their
resume so they found this out they fixed
it right
we also see instances of bias based on
race and ethnicity there's a tweet on
the left that shows how a black man was
tagged using an image recognition system
solely with terms related to race and
ethnicity
instead of other tags when he had used
other images of white men which would
say things like doctor or parents or
handsome and then on the right is a
screenshot from a New York Times article
showing how popular smart speakers
were essentially
misidentifying words from black people
more so than white people
all right and so this is black and white
you know there are many other layers in
between but this is really showing how
there's not only gender bias but there's
race related bias as well and then there
are these big implications for this type
of bias based on race or gender such as
in healthcare or in mortgage algorithms
and there are tons of others examples of
this in this one book that I really like
if you have not yet read it I'd highly
encourage it it's weapons of math
destruction by Kathy O'Neill which
really highlights
tons of examples in how bias is
exhibited in systems at a large at a
scalable level
so these these examples that I've just
presented primarily focus on race or
gender but identity is
multi-faceted right so this is an image
of Oprah Winfrey she is not just female
and not just black but the intersection
of both of them and so this screenshot
shows how this image of Oprah is
incorrectly identified as male with a
very fairly strong confidence metric
here 76 percent certain that Oprah
Winfrey is male which is you know very
wrong 100 wrong right and there are
similar biases
uh with other examples of people with
these intersectional identities such as
Michelle Obama when she was younger and
she's predicted to be a young man
wearing a black shirt with fairly high
confidence both of which are very wrong
and then there is even confidence levels
very even higher confidence levels that
she is wearing a hairpiece and that's
actually her hair right and so
um these these these systems not only
misclassify Oprah and Michelle Obama but
they also completely failed to
acknowledge these different
intersectional identities of someone is
not just male female but also can be
female and
Etc
all right and so this is what this term
intersectionality really emphasizes it
was made Popular by Kimberly Crenshaw
um and it discusses the unique
experiences of black women and how they
are different from the experiences of
just being a woman or just being
um black and so I have a description of
intersectionality from a paper led by
Sheena orete that describes
intersectionality at this higher level
as emphasizing the importance of
understanding the combination of one's
identities and set up a singular
identity
particularly with historically
minoritized identities that are
discriminated against and kind of don't
benefit from the privilege in ways that
these majority groups do and then often
discuss I have some some circles on the
side here often discuss our identities
like race and gender and ethnicity when
we think about intersectionality but in
today's talk I'm going to be arguing for
extending discussions about
intersectional identities to disability
and older age as they relate to
accessibility more broadly because that
is my particular research area I really
focus on older adults and at least at
the moment blind and low vision
communities and how can they can best be
supported in Computing systems broadly
defined
so the central question guiding
today's presentation is how can human
computer interaction as a field use an
intersectional approach to designing for
disability and so I'm gonna use two
related studies to basically enter this
first sub question of why an
intersectional approach is important and
then end with a study that demonstrates
how an intersectional lens really
affects design
so first why is an intersectional
approach important I'm going to discuss
this in the context of disability
intersecting with older age okay so when
I discuss disability and age I want to
highlight that disability is not
synonymous with aging but it is heavily
correlated with aging so this this the
statistics up here are showing that 15
of the world has one or more
disabilities where when you look at
those who are over the age of 60 that
number significantly increases to 46 of
people have more than one disability and
then similarly with chronic conditions
where one in four adults have at least
two chronic conditions and then when you
look at older adults more than half have
three or more conditions until chronic
conditions so this is why I say that
disability and Ulster age they don't
equate to one another but they are
correlated
similarly disability affects
internet access it really complicates
access to a lot of computing systems
that rely on the internet so I have a
chart up here that is
enlarged and redesigned essentially from
a paper by the bransky and hargit high
where they provide evidence of what they
call this digital disability divide and
so they conducted a survey with people
who identify as disabled and those who
do not and they find that 80 percent of
the respondents without disabilities use
the internet whereas only
47.8 percent of those with disabilities
use the internet and then of those
numbers of those who use the internet
broadly speaking those who have
broadband internet access in their homes
77 percent were people without
disabilities and then for people with
disabilities it was only about 66 so
they're seeing and both of these numbers
were statistically significant so you're
seeing that disability does affect
internet access
but also older age affects internet
access and these numbers are a little
older at the moment but in the most
recent version of this report from Pew
research they show that internet use and
broadband internet access in one's home
dropped significantly when someone is
over the age of 75 and even more
significantly with those who are over
the age of 80. and so both disability
and age affect internet access when
they're studied separately and so you
can only imagine at the intersection of
these two the same problem exists
so in the first part of this this
presentation I'm going to focus again on
the intersection of these two identities
disability and older age
specifically vision loss so blind and
low vision communities because vision
loss is very prevalent among the older
adult population and up here I have a
statistic showing
um describing age-related macular
degeneration which is one type of health
condition that leads to late Life vision
loss so one report states that there
were 11 million older adults in the
United States with age-related macular
degeneration and this number is only
expected to grow I think this report
said that it was expected to double
within the next 30 Years and this was a
report from
2016 which is not that far away now that
we are in two thousand 23.
okay and so you know you might be
thinking well there are tons of
technologies that can support blind and
low vision people lentil vision older
adults in accessing the internet and
that is correct right there are
assistive Technologies like screen
readers or even screened magnifiers that
can support technology access with
vision loss but in my prior work with
blind and low vision older adults
and learned that that was a little bit
more complicated than what I was
expecting it to be so many we
interviewed blind and low vision older
adults and many of them were interested
in engaging online but learning to use
these assistive Technologies became
super overwhelming they're like I do not
want to learn how to use a screen reader
this has a hundred different keyboard
shortcuts I'm never going to remember
all of them and so it became so
overwhelming that those older adults who
were active online before vision loss
often became inactive after the onset of
vision loss experiencing vision loss or
or blindness so yes there are some
technologies that exist but they don't
necessarily solve quote unquote these
issues of access to different online
communities information online Etc
so to support this desire for accessible
online engagement I worked with a group
of students to build an interactive
voice response or ivr a community called
Express and so if you're less familiar
with this this term ivr it's essentially
something that people can interact with
through keypad or voice input often on
some type of phone device
you can think of ivr systems
unfortunately I'm going to lead with a
negative version these customer service
phone trees that are so annoying where
it's like press want to do this press
two to do that that's the annoying
version but there is a better version of
that so we built this this Express
system kind of mimicking that in a sense
but it's it's more of a blogging
Community that's accessible to anyone
that has a phone that can dial a number
so this could this doesn't have to be a
smartphone it could be a landline phone
it could be a non-smartphone and so I
just want to briefly
give a bit more detail about this system
so I did say it was inspired by these
customer service trees but at a higher
level it's actually more so inspired by
a lot of work from researchers in the
global South who find that these
interactive voice response communities
are super helpful for those who either
don't have internet access or face some
type of challenge with with internet
access and so across a two-year
period I had done a series of formative
observations and interviews prototype
testing with older adults in a
particular Long-Term Care Community
right outside of of Northwestern and in
Chicago and it showed how they were
seeking engagement right they wanted to
engage with others online but they hated
accessing a computer like going to this
computer room figuring out how to turn
on the computer and log in and then the
password resets were a whole other story
where you had to reset the password for
one email address and then reset the
password to the backup email address and
the backup so they were like we don't
want to deal with this at all we would
much rather interact by phone by
speaking on a phone and then we we did
some interviews with older adult
bloggers who were really describing how
meaningful blogging was on a computer
they were describing how meaningful it
was as a practice in late life and so
that's why we did decided to kind of
merge this idea of interacting by phone
with some type of blogging Community as
a meaningful kind of engagement
engagement practice so we published the
findings of the formative work in a t
access paper and acai paper so you can
get more of the details if you're
interested in it but I just wanted to
start by briefly walking through how
Express works because you say blogging
on a landline phone and people are often
very confused by that and understandably
so so first when someone dials in
we used twilio which is essentially this
voice Cloud application tool and twilio
routes users to this Python scripts that
then checks a mySQL database so
essentially pull the profile information
of the the number that's coming in the
person who's dialing in to I to
authenticate them to the correct account
so no one needs to use a password at all
which is one of the biggest barriers
that we observed from observations in
this particular uh Long-Term Care
community and so they're authenticated
based on the number that they dial in
from this script then reads out loud a
main menu using text-to-speech and voice
XML and users could do one of three
things so it's not this long complicated
customer service phone tree they could
do one of three things if they press one
they can listen to others posts and
comments if they press two they can
listen to their own posts and comments
and then if they press three they can
record a new a new post and so they're
interacting here and I put up here the
image of the the keypad they're
interacting here through keypad input as
opposed to voice input because of
research which shows if someone is
completely unfamiliar with the system
and you tell them to kind of use voice
input to navigate they're not going to
be sure of how to navigate through that
system so we use keypad input to give
them very specific
um
options of what they could could do
so they interact through keypad input if
they want to listen to others posts or
their own posts they then hear a
recording of that exact
post and also comments they hear the
exact recording and then if they want to
create a post they record the message by
speaking directly into the phone uh
receiver they press a digit to Signal
the end of the post and then they could
either hear that post replayed and
decide that they want to re-record or
hear the post replayed and decide you
know I'm good with this publishes to the
system
so after they published the post the the
address of the audio recording is
installed in the database to be
retrieved anytime someone wants to
listen to a post and the same with the
comment and then it's also made
available to other Express users and so
the benefits of this are that older
adults do not need to purchase an
additional device or learn how to use a
completely unfamiliar system because it
was very similar to not only customer
service phone trees but also voicemail
which
I personally no longer check but someone
still checks their voicemail and so
they're really familiar with this type
of of metaphor and so overall it
expresses enabling us to study new forms
of online interaction amongst mind and
low vision older adults
so before I move to like what we did
with Express how people used it are
there any questions about how it works
anything I can clarify yes
they are happy
to get word birthday something to ensure
that the person who's calling is
actually me and not someone who does
mindful that's a good question we did
not Implement any security mechanisms
here other than the fact that we knew we
asked them what phone number they would
be dialing in from in twilio essentially
can take can pull the phone number of
the person who's dialing and we use that
to authenticate them to the account but
there are lots of questions there are
options to then
um you know give people a particular pin
number they choose a two-digit number or
four digit number when they dial in to
kind of double authenticate them into
that account but we didn't do that in
this case yeah good question
yes
um how is um
I was a user like able to navigate to
like all the information like listening
to other people's posts like how are
they able to
yeah
yeah that's a good question I didn't say
what all of these other numbers did
um so there's the nav the high level
navigation of listen to others listen to
own and create a new post and then when
they go in to listening let's just say
listening to others posts there are ways
that they can skip around in the system
so I think four was replay the post six
will skip to the next post
um and so that way they could kind of
Traverse through the system the posts
were also
um similar to a blog or presented
reverse chronologically so the newest
one was always presented
first and then they could go backwards
from there did that answer good question
[Music]
I don't go back to their way to do that
yeah so that's a great question there is
there was no saving in this version we
were trying to strip blogging down to
its basic fundamentals we had initially
had in some other
um like seven eight and nine or some
other numbers as well zero was always
back to the main menu but then when we
presented it to older adults
it was very confusing so we just removed
those additional features and there were
instances where we
for comments we would um use double
numbers to represent the same thing that
you could do with posts like four four
but replay a comment six six would
replay the post or replay the com or
skip to the next comment very similar to
a post and we found that that was okay
but once we started to reuse numbers for
other things that's when things got
confusing because there is a little bit
of more of a cognitive burden of
listening to
content in an online community than
looking at it visually so that's why we
kind of removed a lot of the additional
features that you might find on the
traditional blogging platform
I feel like there was another question
yes
I suspected the recording from video
audio to text may not work very well as
there are still kind of Technology
limitations how what's the quality of
that process and how easy it is for
users to create a new post make ad dates
Etc so that's a great question because
we that's one of the reasons why we use
the exact recording to play back the
person's post so if they want to create
a new post they record directly into the
phone receiver and then that's the exact
recording that is then played anytime
someone else wants to listen to that
post it's never converted into text and
so part of that was
the the speech to text recognition
wasn't the greatest at the time and
still not always the greatest but also
people really liked the when we
prototyped this system people really
liked the emotion that they can hear
from someone else's voice for through a
direct recording as opposed to having
more of the synthetic speech like they
could get to know whether someone was
being sarcastic or not and so that's why
we kept just the straight recording
did that answer your question okay
okay oh great questions
okay so we then deployed Express to
Blind and low vision older adults and we
wanted to understand how they used this
voice Community
um what afforded meaning in voice
communities what was meaningful and then
what benefits The Voice communities like
Express uh provide
so we worked with several students and
two of which are on pictured here Sam
ankenbauer and pujo Patio to lead to
field deployments with Express so the
first is more of a pilot that was with
seven blind and low vision older adults
they all had acquired vision loss and
this was over a 10 week period and then
the second was a much longer study that
was funded through the Retirement
Research Foundation and it was a
one-year field deployment with 43 blind
and low vision older adults half of
about half of which were assigned to
this intervention condition where they
used Express and about half were
assigned to this control group where
they did not use Express at all and so
for both groups
those who use express and those who
didn't in this one-year deployment
um we did collect a few things at the
one month six month and 12th month
um period specifically we measured
loneliness and social support
so while not significant these measures
around loneliness and social support and
I'll explain a little bit about why in a
few we did notice some Trends so one is
that loneliness decreased for everyone
in the study but this was more
pronounced for those who use express for
those who are in the intervention
condition meaning that this difference
between one month the first month and
the 12th month was larger for those who
used Express
and then we saw similar Trends with
social support where you might have to
kind of flip things in your mind here a
lower social support score here actually
means higher social support right so
um overall people were felt like they
had more social support if they use
express compared to those who
um did not and so we
note that these are Trends and not
statistically significant because we did
this study in the pandemic
um in the height of things right so
everyone was less lonely at the end and
everyone felt more socially supported at
the end so there were people had
different social distancing requirements
depending on what state they were
dialing in from so it was a little bit
messy to see any statistical
significance changes there but we did
see some improvements some Trends we
want to do this at a larger scale we
were seeing some more significant Trends
in the first six months especially
related to loneliness and so we were
kind of thinking well maybe these types
of voice communities are better for
people when they're more extremely
isolated because this was May May of
2020 is when the the first person was
enrolled and so they were enrolled
between May and November of 20
20 and then a year from that they ended
so we're thinking when people are more
extremely isolated maybe these voice
communities could provide support but
beyond this the survey data what what's
most interesting were these qualitative
findings related to disability
um so first blogging by phone using
Express provided opportunities for
meeting new people and connecting on a
deeper level which participants
described was difficult to do elsewhere
so there's a quote from one participant
who said if I'm walking on the street
you would say hi can I help you that was
all you would do you wouldn't say Hi how
are you what can I do for you and so for
him there's always this stigma of having
a quote-unquote visible disability
because you use a white cane to navigate
around barriers in his environment and
so people always assumed that he needed
help when he was out navigating
somewhere instead of you know just
trying to start a conversation without
that assistance component within it so
by using the phone to block he could
more easily talk to people about
different topics
um and participants really valued this
type of depth of of conversation and
connection
participants also described how blocking
by phone was a safe space to work
through disability so they talked about
topics like finding accessible voting
booths or many really rallied around
this one person who described recently
having some vision changes and no longer
being able to drive due to his vision
loss so because of you know the amount
that this was a seven person pilot and
people really valued the the topics in
the system I said okay well what if we
were to increase the number of people
who were using this system we had
already done a study where I'd
interviewed older adults who were
blogging sighted older adult bloggers
who were already very involved with
blogging and so I said I asked the
participants in this the study the Blind
and low vision older adults you know you
all seem to be wanting some more content
in this system do you mind if I invite
Society older adult bloggers and
initially everyone was on board with
that all seven participants said that
would be great to hear from other people
they're also older like maybe we can
learn from them or maybe they can learn
from us Etc
but after the blinds and the vision
older adults actually heard the content
from the sighted older adults
they definitely changed their minds and
so one person said I can get that
anywhere I don't need to have a certain
site that's just for the visually
challenged to have everybody else in
there so they actually did not have
their hearing the content they did not
want cited older adults to be on this
system at all because they hear the
experiences they call them the majority
they hear the experiences of the
majority daily and they really value
this being a system that was
specifically for blind Innovation older
adults now they said well maybe they
could listen but they shouldn't be able
to contribute maybe they could listen
and learn about disability but we don't
want to hear what they have to say
particularly I remember some of these
pills where some of the cited bloggers
were talking about how beautiful of a
day it was and how the colors were
shining and it's like
that's not what they want to hear in
this in this community so these these
data points helped us to understand the
boundaries on community
participation and also highlighted the
importance of Designing for intersecting
disability experiences
so what I mean by that it's um more so
like just because someone is an older
adult it doesn't mean that their
experiences are the same as a blind and
low vision older adult and similarly if
someone is younger and has some type of
vision impairment that does not mean
that their experiences are going to be
the same as someone who is older with a
vision impairment so these Concepts
around
intersectionality intersectional
critical theory have really typically
been discussed in the context of race
class or gender studies uh describing
again this this importance of the
intersection of two or more oppressed
groups and here I'm using this
intersectional lens to really discuss
the intersection of age and disability
so kind of returning back to this
original question
of why it is important to use an
intersectional approach but really here
we're saying that it can really impact
the value that someone places on a
community or participants really valued
the community when it was only blind and
low vision older adults and they didn't
want to really use it one-sided people
started to come and quote unquote
Infiltrate The System
right so can impact the value that
someone places on on community
now the last part of this talk I wanted
to briefly use some recent work to
discuss how an intersectional approach
might affect design but before this is
kind of a separate ish topic although
it's connected by intersectionality were
there any questions on the previous
study with Express yes
it was all organic we did after their
initial
um
Cree
interview we said hey like try it out
let us know if you have any questions we
recommend trying to listen to One post
and create one post and comment on one
post but after that we didn't have any
requirements for use because we want we
didn't want to force them to use
something
are they using like smartphones or just
the old school
physical bones yeah most were using
landline phones
um because we did do some in-home visits
during the the first interview at least
for the pilot study we know that most
were using landline phones for the
second study that was in May of 2020
where we weren't exactly sure what types
of phones they were using but from the
pilot we did learn that they preferred
um landline phones with a raised buttons
so that they could tell which button
they were pressing instead of having to
use a screen reader and kind of swipe
through
um to figure out what button they were
pressing on it on a touch screen so yeah
most were using landline at least in the
pilot and I imagine if it wasn't
landline for the full deployment a lot
we're also using
um phone smart or cell phones with
raised buttons so more like feature or
non-smart phones
is it is it possible for users to kind
of like I guess like form groups within
people like while using um the
application where it's just like
whether it's a specific topic they're
equal to kind of
like golf courses the inflow of topics
right so instead of presenting the
topics kind of or the posts reverse
chronological order could they find
different topics
not in this version though and so that
was something that people said that they
wanted and we were trying to figure out
a way to do this without
reusing too many buttons on the phone or
like ways to do that through speech
might be another way
um moving forward and it did seem like
people were forming their own
kind of mini groups where they would
always go back and listen to the same
people's pose and comment on the same
people's pose but not in a in a formal
it wasn't formally structured that way
mm-hmm
yes I'm curious if you got the sort of
common online community dynamics of like
I don't know influencers lurkers that
kind of stuff or did it was it in any
way is transmogrified by the context
here we did and I I'm wondering if I
have a backup side but yes
um we did see that there were especially
in the one year long deployment we were
able to see those patterns a bit more
where there were people who were
um we caught them top listeners and they
were people who were top posters and
often they did not intersex like there
was a whole group of people who was
listening
um and then they were alert sometimes
called lurking and then there was a
whole group of people who were always
contributing the content so we did see
kind of those similar
um contribution patterns there and our
next step is to actually I'm supposed to
be working on this in the next month or
so writing a paper at where we
um like provide more detail about the
narratives of how listeners and posters
use the system because they use it in
different ways
um often it mimicked their interactions
on screen based online communities where
people would say like Oh I'm a lurker on
Facebook and I also am a lurker here
they didn't actually use those words but
essentially it did mimic their behavior
in other other communities
mm-hmm
all right so next again we're going to
get into how can HCI use an
intersectional approach to design and
specifically how my intersectionality
affect design itself and so this is a
study that focuses on the intersection
of disability and ethnicity this work
was led by PhD student Rahat Al Harvey
at University of Michigan as part of a
team with Sharita shonabet and this next
project focuses on visual description or
visual assistance services like
Microsoft's seeing AI which is very
helpful for describing a visual content
to Blind and low vision people so we
have a few examples here of this
particular app is useful for describing
short text details about people about
products or cans about currency what are
these different bills Etc
but it's also helpful in describing
content uh private content like social
security cards right but the tricky part
is what happens when someone uses these
visual description applications to
either intentionally or unintentionally
take a photo of sensitive or private
content so take this obviously very fake
uh social security card on the screen
there are lots of privacy implications
with sensitive content like social
security cards or even credit card
numbers or Bank application or bank
routing numbers Etc
and so while not currently an option A
lot of privacy researchers and
accessibility researchers are advocating
for obfuscation or intentionally hiding
content or blurring content for privacy
reasons but then there are these other
questions that arise from that like you
know is obfuscation always the right
approach or what type of obfuscation is
it blurring out the a specific part of
an image or is it blurring out the
background and only leaving a certain
part and then also how can we better
incorporate feedback a lot of this this
discussion around obfuscation is really
driven by privacy researchers how can we
actually include and incorporate
feedback from the Blind and low vision
community
so then we did a study and the two
primary questions for this study guiding
the study are one witness obfuscation
useful for blind and low vision people
and then two what are the barriers to
these obfuscation approaches
and so just for the purposes of time I'm
going to focus on this second research
question to barriers to obfuscation
approaches and so for this study We're
Half started by recruiting on social
media and through the national uh
Federation of the Blind and from this
very intentional recruitment process we
learned specific challenges that blind
and low vision people at the
intersection of different ethnicities of
different ages of different genders of
different disabilities other
disabilities anticipated
facing with obfuscation
so one of these challenges is related to
the Social Security number example one
is well what if people don't want
sensitive content hidden like what if
they're filling out a form and they
actually need to hear social security
number information or they need to hear
credit card information read out loud
um so one participant Clara pseudonym
provided another example when she said I
don't know my bank number off the top of
my head but I might want it to be read
out loud to me right so there are
instances where obfuscation is actually
not something that should happen or at
least not obfuscation in the sense that
the number itself is is always hidden
maybe everything around it is hidden and
then the number is shown
in another context David said
um you know you're following some
navigation and it senses something in
the environment that it deems as
inappropriate and blurs it out but all
of a sudden an agent can't see a street
sign or something because it's actively
being occluded that's definitely going
to be a dangerous a dangerous problem so
more so in a navigation context if
you're walking and actually you need to
see certain details about your
environment or need to hear them
described in order to get from point A
to point B safely so you know one
solution to this you might be thinking
is you can ask people
each time they use the system whether
they want sensitive content to be hidden
like Social Security numbers or bank
accounts or street sign names but we are
arguing in this work that this is then
placing a lot of burden on the disabled
user a lot of Labor and it's kind of on
one hand and then also it's kind of
difficult to
um know what is deemed quote unquote
sensitive right that can differ for
context to context culture to culture
day to day person to person
and so sad illustrates this dilemma of
deciding what is sensitive or private
when he said in the Middle East there
are more concerned about their families
especially towards females and stuff on
the other hand in the U.S for example
medication is a big deal so people in
the U.S consider medication a very
private thing whereas in the Middle East
it is not a big deal
so this work or this particular quote is
extending prior work on
um privacy preserving mechanisms amongst
Muslim American women and it's it's
showing that it it may be difficult to
have an automated approach relying on
this quote-unquote Universal set of of
private items and it's suggesting that
blind and low vision people are aware
that the data that powers these systems
are biased usually towards Western uh
countries and Western contexts so what
would it mean to more strongly consider
disability identities intersecting
disabilities that intersect with
ethnicity or you know other cultures as
as well when designing designing systems
informing how data is collected how data
is stored how data is presented and kind
of just doing data work more broadly
so again to return to this question of
how might an intersectional approach
affect uh design well it might inform us
of you know the biases the biases that
we have in our systems in this case
image related data privacy related data
favoring more Western societies Western
disability perspectives and really
highlighting these challenges that exist
at this intersection of disability and
ethnicity
and so our next steps are to work with
blinds and low vision people more in a
co-design sense to really understand
more about how we can do this in a more
meaningful way how can we create
obfuscation experiences how can we be
more
um transparent in what is going on
Within These systems
um in ways that are meaningful to to
them and that could support approaches
like obfuscation
um but at a higher level these questions
also connect to how to best represent
intersecting identities within a data
context so I've worked with some folks
here in the audience today Michael in
June
um to show how current data sets don't
do well that even representing one
identity right in identity fasted in
this case being age and older age
specifically but then there are open
questions about you know how can data
better represent multiple identities
particularly Beyond race ethnicity and
gender like these three that are the
focus what about one disability what
about two disabilities what about older
age what about
um you know any any other thing outside
of race and gender how can we do that
and and a more
um kind of sensitive way and a more
nuanced way
so with that I'd like to thank my mini
collaborators students and and funding
sources and kind of use this as a we
have about 15-ish minutes left to answer
uh any any questions that you might have
so thank you
[Applause]
questions someone jump in and I'll hand
you the mic
thank you
um so I'm curious to hear your thoughts
on
universality versus pluralism some of us
actually taking a course with Michael
have just been talking about some of
these things and especially with as it
relates to intersectionality the
trade-offs between thinking of a
Universal Design like a ramp on a curb
that works for everyone versus something
that's really specially designed for a
specific Community
um that's a pretty broad question but
I'm interested to hear your thoughts on
it
yeah so that's a great question around
this this concept of whether
universality is the right approach when
is it versus isn't
um and what we're seeing is that
everything especially in the HCI
Community if you ask a question the
answer is usually going to be it depends
right and so there are questions more so
questions around how can we best
use information data about people
that can help them to make the best
decision in different contexts right so
the context might be all right I am on a
street and I am trying to navigate and
it is
cloudy or something right so these more
contextual approaches I think are more
so where we are leaning so that it can
be flexible and things can change as
opposed to having a universal thing but
then that also means having enough
information not only about the context
itself but about the user and right now
we don't have enough information about
the user to then be able to merge
context plus user to inform the best
decision
so yeah great question
yes a great talk
it doesn't it doesn't amplify recording
yeah okay
um so great talk I really enjoyed it for
the first part I wonder which User Group
specifically x-price is going to help
the most especially in terms of
loneliness or social support my
suspicion is that if someone has a very
strong real world social network or
social support system they may not
benefit a lot from this type of system
versus if they don't have like strong
real world support then maybe this type
of technology technology would work well
I wonder whether there are any insights
from the studies yeah that's a really
great question I think we were a little
bit limited by a few things to be able
to detect any differences there one was
how we recruited participants so we
partnered with the national Federation
of the blind for Recruitment and for
that we actually got a lot of
participants from the New Jersey
National Federation of the blind chapter
for some reason but they're already be
connected some of some of the
participants were already connected to
these Community nfe communities and so
it was hard to know like is it that
people are already connected or not
there were a couple of people who in
their pre-interviews we asked these
questions of you know are you connected
to any other communities how do you
engage with other people how do you
engage with other blind people they're
older adults and there were a couple who
were in rural environments one person
was in such a rural environment that she
was saying yeah we don't have Uber or
Lyft out here to go to the grocery store
I have to hire a driver and this is my
husband my permanent driver for the last
five years Etc so we definitely saw that
there were some differences between
those who were dialing into nfv chapters
there were even like a president of an
NFC chapter compared to those who were
like more in a rural context and that's
more so why we're trying to present more
these qualitative narratives of how
people use the system just because we
didn't have enough for participant so
out of the
there were 43 total and I think there
was like 21 in one group and 22 in the
other group let's say 21 was the the
intervention group who used Express out
of that 21 I would say about 10 were
active enough for us to be able to look
at their pre and post
um survey data and so we just really
scale wise we can't we couldn't really
detect like it was because this person
was more connected and this one was less
connected but that's definitely
something to to consider so one was how
connected were they before the study
started and then there were also
questions of how connected were they
during the study which we got from some
of the six months and even for those in
the intervention condition we contacted
them every three months of like how are
things changing where you are
um
some were like out and about as soon as
they could get out and about and others
were not
um based on social distancing
requirements in their area or even how
they cook it out so there were also
questions about how social distancing
might have affected how social they were
with other people during the duration of
this study but yes that all of those
will impact the use that they get out of
this system
there was another version of it wasn't
it wasn't Express but it kind of led to
express it was called Vmail which is
essentially expressed but for checking
email and for those who use assistive
Technologies and who had computers in
their home they weren't really dialing
into Vmail because they already had
existing mechanisms to be able to do
that and so you would think that that
could also transfer to the express
Community where if they already have
these social environments maybe they're
using it less or maybe they're not
deriving as much benefit from it as
maybe someone who's a bit more socially
isolated
foreign
curious to get your advice
um
one reaction to the challenges of
intersectional design is that we should
you just turn it all the way up to 11
and go all the way to like Mass
customization like every like everyone
should be able to very easily
personalize for their own you know for
their own issues and their own use that
is a particular like a design angle we
might offer the other would be to think
through a design process that's still
creating sort of groups of some sort
their intersectional groups but
designing you know sort of by sampling
around is a different intersection
intersectional identity groups and and
doing it that way I'm curious in the
systems and designs that you're
envisioning in the future and I
how should we as designers be thinking
about that kind of process should we be
starting from a point of okay how do we
actually you know on the assumption that
the inner that the intersectional
identities are going to cause this Mass
proliferation of different context
different needs should we just start
from the assumption that everyone's
going to be different or should we in
our design process be starting by
identifying you know again cells in in
The Matrix so to speak yeah that's a
great question um and that's really a
big question right now in like the fast
community and the fairness space and how
do we measure fairness that different
groups have different
definitions of what fairness means and
we can't segment too much because then
we can't get any meaningful data I think
I'm coming at well two things I'm coming
at it more from a lens of understanding
intersectional identities in terms of
understanding how people are using these
systems right understanding these
narratives of use of not solely saying
oh older adults did this one thing and
younger adults did this one thing but
there might be a little bit more Nuance
to unpack there so really even looking
at these groups and saying are there
other things that we might be missing
because we're only focusing on one
identity instead of you know black
younger adults are thinking this versus
lack older adults are thinking that so
more so the lens for interpreting how
people are using the system in more of a
qualitative approach but then also
part of this is
um you know you can't really
separate people into I don't think we're
there yet in terms of being even able to
separate people into these different
smaller buckets because we don't have
enough data about those smaller buckets
right we might have a couple of things
and like race and gender
maybe age and sometimes that's a good
thing right because it preserves privacy
of individuals who are using these
systems but on the other hand we're
Limited in being able to say all right
now we're going to pull people from this
group and this group and bucket them
together I think being able to have that
flexibility would be nice I don't think
we'd have to segment to every possible
type of combination of someone's
identities but we could say okay from
this qualitative data we're seeing that
um you know black older adults are
distinctly different from other users in
this system all right now I'm going to
pull data just from black older adults I
don't think we have to segment it into
every possible option but more so using
the qualitative data to then inform how
we're looking at things more
quantitatively but we're a little bit
limited on how we can do that right now
and to pull that thread what advice
would you have to
say like students in like a you know
intro to design intro to HCI style
course where they're going to go out and
they need to go you know do you need
finding observation and you know their n
is not that big right right is is this
about tying the
the observations we see two broader
narratives around intersectional
identities or there are other things
they how can they be sensitive to these
issues
I think one big thing and I'm I'm
actually
coaching students through this in a
class right now
um well not right now but this semester
um in terms of
a lot of research so this this class
that I'm teaching is a project-based
class of accessibility where students
work on projects related to disability
and older age and they go through the
full like research and design life cycle
um
and I start the class off with a lot of
research and accessibility space focuses
on primarily white women
and so you have to be very intentional
about
um like including people in even these
class projects in these smaller scale
projects that are outside of what is
very convenient to recruit so I think
part of it is just like in these smaller
scale projects being sure that you have
different identities represented it's
probably not going to be every identity
that's possible or identity combination
that's possible but there shouldn't be
like only one type of identity that you
are engaging to understand how people
interact with systems and products Etc
and so that's more so of I think at the
the lower level for these like smaller
projects is probably what I would
recommend I think then once you
transition to say a student who's
interning somewhere or student who is
has graduated and then goes off to work
at companies where they then have access
to much larger
sample sizes or populations or vendors
Etc
that then you could use those same
principles of not just recruiting one
type of person but do so at a larger
scale and then be able to draw out some
of these qualitative narratives of use
thank you yeah
thank you so much for this talk I really
loved um like how Express maintains a
lot of cultural context for blind and
low vision people kind of talking about
the second part of your talk I was
interested in like thinking about the
impact of Express on people who might
speak English as a second language just
like different cultural backgrounds I'm
wondering if you
um like noticed any insights around that
or what your vision is of the potential
impact of Express on those communities
just because there must be like a ton of
nuance
in terms of like English as a second
language and verbal input
um different levels of comfort that's a
really yeah that's an amazing question
in this particular study just because
the
um like the the scales of loneliness and
social support that we were using we're
all in in English we did have like are
you comfortable with English we didn't
have it as your first language but are
you comfortable with speaking in English
to participate in this study is kind of
a criteria for eligibility
um but there are lots of questions
particularly within research in in the
global South the people who might not be
literate
um preferring to use these voice related
voice communities and voice systems ivr
systems but then you also get into
questions around language there as well
because sometimes the language is in
written and so voice is like the best
way to to interact I think voice has
affordances for
um people of different cultures and
different languages has its strengths
what we haven't done yet is think about
how
um well this could be this is just an
idea that I'm throwing out here how
people
of different
um people who speak different languages
could be in a voice Community together
and so it might go back to well maybe we
do have some type of way for the speech
to be translated to text and then that
text could be whatever language the user
primarily speaks and so that they can
interact with people across languages
like that could be an option but that's
not something that we we have considered
so far I think we're about in time so
why don't we thank our speaker
[Applause]